Ralph Waldo Emerson once quoted that Ted
nothing great can ever be achieved
without enthusiasm
I have a lot of enthusiasm this great
big story was made possible by Geico
believe it
Geico could save you 15% or more on car
insurance
[Music]
this is Northlands in Flemington New
Jersey Northlands is the world's largest
model railroad well I guess you know
everybody has a passion for something my
thing was trains had trains around the
Christmas tree as a kid wherever I lived
I'm planning check plans and then over
18 years I added five basements onto the
house and from that I got fairly good at
making mountains and bridges and design
work and we decided to give it to the
world so we tore it all down bought this
land built Northlands any given day we
run between 85 and 90 trains some of the
details in Northlands inside about
40,000 feet of track about 4,000
buildings over 400 bridges many of the
mountains in here are three and a half
stories high most things in here are
scratch built underneath the entire
superstructure there's enough lumber to
build about 42 large houses it takes a
few hours to go through for the average
person to see everything we want
millions into debt to build this place
everywhere I thought we were nuts the
only one that believed that what I
wanted to do was my wife and she was
totally with me on this big time it's an
artistic endeavor it's a gift to the
world of what I can do and it makes a
lot of people happy
you